everybody knows I'm a big Arnold
Schwarzenegger fan especially since the
days of uh Conan the Barbarian
absolutely I really am I always thought
that movie was uh brilliant and I knew
you'd be great in it and I've liked all
your movies you know that I'm a big fan
but can I just tell you my favorite
scene in this movie okay go ahead oh
here we go well there's two favorite
things when Jamie Lee strips well yeah I
love Arnold's reaction when he drops the
tape recorder and all that that was good
you know the amazing things in the scene
I had to drop the tape recorder that's
supposed to speak in a French accent
right right so she doesn't know it's me
because there was you know I was trying
to pull a trick on her and uh in the
meantime after two two minutes of of
doing this trip this I trap it naturally
because it was and I was so shocked to
see her because I haven't seen the
rehearsal to see her stripping in front
of me so I trapped the tape recorder and
Jim Cameron the director was screaming I
don't know how many times did it tell
you to do exactly what I tell you I mean
this is called improvisation don't drop
the tape record I didn't say you should
drop it I said listen I couldn't help it
I'm in my mouth and they left it in my
hand you know they kept it in yeah I
love the scene with the horse oh that
was good
is incredible that was really good we're
talking about the Conan days I mean if I
wouldn't have done all the horseback
riding on the Conan movie I mean I don't
know how I would have done those scenes
with the horse that's actually you
riding that horse oh yeah I mean you
know I had to really uh Chase uh you
know this scene doing the scene chasing
the terrorists and a motorcycle we used
four different horses see I'm thinking
of putting a horse in my movie now since
I saw Arnold's movie I might be doing
some horseback ride yeah well we're in
the middle of writing it so I just you
know I'm just gonna throw a horse in
it's amazing I think you should but the
only thing is this key the key trick
there is is to just ride every day for
two hours a month before Oh I don't need
to do that no but I'm telling you when
you get on the set I'm gonna ride a
donkey maybe a little bit better but
this is less predictable you know